Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Después de ser testigo de la ira violenta
mostrada por los bebés
siempre que se les priva de un elemento
que consideraban suyo,
Jean Piaget, uno de los fundadores
de la psicología infantil,
observado algo profundo
sobre la naturaleza humana.
Nuestro sentido de propiedad
surge muy temprano.
¿Por qué somos tan aferradizos?
Hay un fenómeno
bien establecido en psicología
conocido como el efecto de dotación
por el que valoramos mucho más altamente
las cosas, tan pronto como los poseemos.
En una famosa demostración,
a unos estudiantes se les dio a elegir
entre una taza de café
o una barra de chocolate suizo
como recompensa por su ayuda
con la investigación.
La mitad eligió la taza,
y la otra mitad eligió el chocolate.
Es decir, que parecían valorar
las dos recompensas de manera similar.
A otros estudiantes se les dio
primero una taza
y luego una posibilidad sorpresiva
de cambiarla por una barra de chocolate,
pero solo el 11% quiso.
Sin embargo,
otro grupo comenzó con el chocolate,
y la mayoría prefirieron conservarlo
a hacer el intercambio.
En otras palabras, los estudiantes
casi siempre dan mayor valor
a la recompensa inicial.
En parte tiene que ver con
la rapidez con que hacemos conexiones
entre nuestro sentido de nosotros mismos
y las cosas que consideramos nuestras.
Que incluso se pueden ver
a nivel neuronal.
En un experimento, neurólogos escanearon
los cerebros de los participantes
antes de que se asignen varios objetos,
o bien a una cesta etiquetada "mía"
u otra etiquetada, "De Alex".
Cuando los participantes luego
miraron sus nuevas cosas,
sus cerebros mostraron una mayor actividad
en una región que por lo general
parpadea en la realidad
cada vez que pensamos
en nosotros mismos.
Otra razón por la que somos
tan apegados a nuestras posesiones
es que desde una edad temprana
creemos que tienen una esencia única.
Los psicólogos nos muestran esto
mediante el uso de la ilusión
de convencer a niños de 3 a 6 años que
construyeron una máquina que copia,
capaz de crear réplicas perfectas
de cualquier artículo.
Cuando se les ofreció elegir
entre su juguete favorito
o una copia aparentemente exacta,
la mayoría de los niños
favoreció el original.
De hecho, a menudo se horrorizaron ante la
posibilidad de llevarse a casa una copia.
Este pensamiento mágico acerca de
los objetos no es algo se vaya a crecer.
Más bien se persiste en la edad adulta,
aunque se hace cada vez más elaborada.
Por ejemplo, consideremos el enorme valor
que se da a artículos
que han sido propiedad de celebridades.
Es como si los compradores creyeran
que los objetos que compran
fueron de alguna forma imbuidos en la
esencia de sus célebres antiguos dueños.
Por razones similares, somos reacios
a desprendernos de herencias familiares
que nos ayudan a sentirnos conectados
con nuestros seres queridos.
Estas creencias pueden llegar a alterar
nuestra percepción del mundo físico
y cambiar nuestras capacidades atléticas.
A los participantes en un estudio reciente
se les dijo que estaban
usando un palo de golf
propiedad del,
una vez campeón, Ben Curtis.
Durante el experimento,
percibían el hoyo como si fuera
como un centímetro más grande
que el de los participantes de control
que usaban un "putter" estándar
y lograron algunos "putts" más.
Aunque los sentimientos de propiedad
emergen temprano en la vida,
la cultura también desempeña un papel.
Por ejemplo, recientemente se descubrió
que los Hadza del norte de Tanzania
que están aislados de la cultura moderna
no exhiben el efecto de dotación.
Esto es posiblemente debido a que
viven en una sociedad igualitaria
donde casi todo se comparte.
En el otro extremo, a veces nuestro apego
a nuestras cosas puede ir demasiado lejos.
Parte de la causa
del trastorno de acumulación
es un exagerado sentido de responsabilidad
y protección hacia las
pertenencias propias.
Es por eso que las personas
con esta condición
les resulta tan difícil de tirar algo.
Lo que queda por ver hoy
es como la naturaleza de nuestra relación
con nuestras posesiones
va a cambiar con la aparición
de las tecnologías digitales.
Muchos han pronosticado la desaparición
de los libros y la música física,
pero por ahora, al menos,
esto parece prematuro.
Tal vez siempre habrá algo
satisfactoriamente único
sobre tener un objeto en nuestras manos
y decir que es nuestro.